But let's look at each of these choices, one at a time. The first one says yes,
because in order for a result to be creative, it must be novel,
an output of an algorithm cannot be novel. Well, there are a few problems with
this particular answer. What if an output of an algorithm for
a small, closed-word problem cannot be novel?
The output of combinations of algorithms for open ended problem can and
indeed sometimes is novel. There are algorithms for example, that do design or
that do scientific discovery, whose results are novel. Let's look at the second
answer. Yes, because given a set of input, the output will always be the same.
Therefore, the product can never be unexpected. The output will
depend not just on the input. And not only on the methods of the system, but
also the situation in which the methods are situated.
The output depends not just on the input under the method the AI agent uses, but
also the context in which the AI agent is situated. For example,
given the same input but different context or the input, the agent will come up
with very different outputs, very different understandings of
that same input as we saw in this section on understanding. The third answer,
no because it defines creativity in terms of the output rather than the process.
This answer too has problems, because sometimes creativity can be defined simply
in terms of the output without knowing anything about the process.
We can think of a black box, that creates very interesting creative music. We
would not know anything about the process that it is using. But, if the output's
interesting and creative music, we would consider it to be creative. Personally,
my sympathies lie with the fourth answer. But, of course you are welcome to
disagree with me. Why don't we continue this discussion on the forum?